des journalistes interpellé menotté
incarcéré voilà qui pourrait devenir la
norme en france
c'est en tout cas ce que suggère le
nouveau schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre
un document de 29 pages qui reconnaît je
cite la place particulière des
journalistes au sein des manifestations
le délit constitué par le fait de se
maintenir dans un attroupement après
sommation ne comporte aucune exception y
compris au profit des journalistes ou de
membres d'associations
dès lors qu'ils sont au coeur d'un
attroupement ils doivent comme n'importe
quel citoyen obtempéré aux injonctions
des représentants des forces de l'ordre
en se positionnant en dehors des
manifestants appelés à se disperser
en clair les journalistes et
observateurs des différentes ong
pourraient donc être interpellés et
poursuivis lors de manifestations et
cela dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions
alors pourra éviter d'en arriver là
le ministère de l'intérieur propose
reporter et ce n'est pas une blague
une sorte de stage de bonne conduite il
sera proposé aux journalistes des
sensibilisations au cadre juridique des
manifestations au cas d'emploi de la
force et notamment aux conduites à tenir
lorsque les sommations sont prononcés
ainsi qu'aux dispositions du snm mot le
texte aborde aussi la question de
l'équipement et de la sécurité des
journalistes
une centaine d'entre eux ont été blessés
ou molestés lors de manifestations de
gilet jaune
c'est donc d' usage pour un reporter
aujourd'hui d'être muni d'un attirail de
protection la nécessité de préserver
l'intégrité physique des journalistes
sur le terrain et réaffirmé hu égard à
l'environnement dans lequel ils évoluent
les journalistes peuvent porter des
équipements de protection dès lors que
leur identification est confirmée et
leur comportement exemple de toute
infraction ou provocation qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
dès lors que leur identification est
confirmé qu'un journaliste doit
systématiquement présenté sa carte de
presse
on le rappelle une nouvelle fois elle
n'est pas obligatoire pour exercer le
métier de journaliste leur comportement
exempt de toute infraction ou
provocation quoi qu il va peut-être
falloir être accrédités pour couvrir une
manifestation sur la voie publique
que dans le cas contraire ce serait
assimilée à une infraction à une
provocation
quoi qu'il en soit ce nouveau schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre a fait
bondir le syndicat national des
journalistes qui évoque clairement une
volonté de restreindre la liberté
d'informer
la philosophie de ce texte c'est hors de
nos rangs point de salut
mais pourquoi ne pas donner d'uniforme
ou journalistes aussi tant qu on y est
je pense que le ministre gérald darmanin
méconnaît la liberté de la presse
il est dans le déni ce texte n'essayez
pas de comprendre notre métier il est
fait pour restreindre la liberté
d'informer on veut transformer les
journalistes en propagandistes comme les
états unis l'ont été prouvé pendant la
guerre du golfe
nous allons donc réaffirmer la liberté
des journalistes qui est de pouvoir être
témoin de tout partout et à tout moment
atteinte à la liberté de la presse
volonté de censure et de contrôler
l'information
l'indignation est la même sur la toile
prochaine étape le ministère de
l'intérieur rédige les papiers ils
veulent juste des journalistes qui serve
leurs intérêts le vrai travail de
journaliste comme beaucoup le font dans
les manifs ou hot les dérange du coup
brassard chasuble ne les intéresse pas
la seule chose que cherche le pouvoir
c'est d'éviter certaines images 1,6 meur
la liberté de la presse et la liberté
d'informer je pense que ça va vite être
retoquée au conseil constitutionnel je
prends les paris des journalistes
interpellés
incarcéré une image qui peut choquer
dans un pays comme la france celui des
droits de l'homme et pourtant elles ont
déjà eu lieu
c'était le cas récemment d'adrien à deux
cases reporter aux médias libres
interpellé le 12 septembre manifestation
est placée en garde à vue au motif
suivant attroupement en vue de commettre
des violences ces refus d'un ordre de
dispersion dans la même journée on a
aussi assisté à l'arrestation de julian
morrow journaliste indépendant
grièvement blessé au visage lors de la
manifestation du 16 novembre 2019
lui s'est en plus fait confisquer son
matériel de protection
la france tient la 34e place sur 180 au
classement de la liberté de la presse
établi par reporters sans frontières la
question s est de savoir pour combien de
temps sa poésie
on pourrait en effet dégringolé dans les
années à venir